[Music]
hey guys
gimme turns just published another
teaser for its final season and it
officially confirms long-standing leak
and theory regarding the battle for vena
fell the ancestral home of house start
will fall along with many characters the
after my teaser shows a spinner felt
devastated by a major battle it's not an
actual aftermath as it's not the actual
season 8 footage but still there's many
things that can get out of it first we
have a start banner flap in the vent
it's better than torn the camera pens
why then we see a completely destroyed
inner courtyard of NFL drilling the
serous fly around the camera then pans
to the side then we see a durable stage
that's guarding the vengeful crypts
here's a broken door in the walkway that
wraps around the inner courtyard and now
in the midst of all that wreckage we
start seeing all these most recognizable
items belonging to our favorite
characters abandoned and covered by snow
first we see Tyrion scanned of the Queen
pin that Danny gave to him at the end of
season 6 lying on snow next to see a
room filled with armor and shields which
are a sword needle stuck in the ground
Devin get a shot of the walkway along
the battlements and then the feather
from the crypts of NFL shows up the one
Robert blue Tinley in a stark statue way
back in season one and the same one
sense effect in season 5 so I think this
represents sense as item everyone has
money next we see a broken wheel that
belongs to brands broken wheelchair
leather Jaime Lannister is gonna hand
right next to Danny's three-headed
dragon chain that hangs on a broken
wheel which is kind of poetic if you
remembered any speech about the wheel in
season 5 and how she wants to break it
finally we have Justin's already and
still sword Lanka
what's interesting here is the long
cloak has blood all over it and yet the
army of the day does not bleed at the
very end if you look closely on this
shot you can also see the knight King
under arch walking through the
Winterfell gates so what does all of
this mean well first of these thieves
are much like the crypts of NFL teaser
from earlier this year does not contain
any actual footage from season 8 it's
more of a hint of what's to come and no
it's not that all these characters whose
items we see in snow
they will not release not during the
battle from NFL the living will lose
winner fell to the night King but almost
all the main characters in fact every
main character cuz they if you think
this teaser thing is this definitely not
going to die
John Dana Tyrion Jamie saying sorry a
brain and none of them are going to die
in a battle for Venna FAL the only thing
it confirms is that they will lose
Winnefeld of the night king which
confirms the long-standing leaked photos
of NFL set being on fire and all the
lifeless bodies we saw it dawn covered
by snow some thought Winterfell set was
being destroyed on purpose to throw us
off but this is not the official
confirmation that winter will not
certainly fall it finna fell if you have
been following game trans seasoning news
and leaked photos you know that you
already expected this battle and if the
aftermath or the outcome we already know
that the big battle for NFL is set to
take place in season 8 and it's been
confirmed to take place in the 3rd
episode of the final season by nectar
who plays the night king let my verdict
after seven seasons the night king has
finally breached the wall is Marcia's
army south even though venom fell will
not be the first Castle to get destroyed
its path he will arrive over there by
the 3rd episode which is in this epic
battle for benefit begins further
declare the new slip during a fan
convention Hungary is an inspiring third
episode of the last season there's a
battle that creator's intended to be a
historic moment in television almost the
full episode will be about a battle
it'll take about one hour thirty states
they filmed this battle for three months
in the wind and rain outdoors and then
for another month in a huge studio which
makes this far and away the most
labor-intensive battle sequence in the
show's history and therefore in the
history of TV I can tell you that there
will be no shortage of surprises in
season 8 for the continues there will
also be a lot of dragons the night king
will return and in season the biggest
battle for the throne will be completed
guarantee me a vehicle's cover story
from a few months back gave us an inside
look into the final game interim season
through the eyes of James Hebert it's
shaping up to be what probably almost
certainly is the longest consecutive
battle sequence in cinema history
Hebert said and continued with they
hoped to try and find other ones out
there like the one in the two towers in
the Lords of the Rings which is about 40
minutes and in the movies 13 assassins
which was also around 40 minutes
is going to be longer than 40 minutes
it's pretty nuts HBO has also gotten
only non sets for season eight building
out the NFL said to make it as close to
real castle as possible
according to Hibbert the crew was up to
the challenge the massive expanding the
vanaf asset you can wound around point a
camera at any direction and it shows
Morvan FL one of the directors pointed
out that even in a big-budget Marvel or
Star Wars movie they usually build what
an actor's are going to stand directly
in front of and fill the rest with green
screen but for this set and a few others
as well they built it as 360-degree set
so you don't have to fill it with
special effects you don't have to favor
one particular angle you can have
cameras follow people around you can do
unusual angles and come up with
different things on the day of shooting
so it allows a lot more creativity and
it helps the actors no acting required
they're running around this sets
fighting fake blood on snow snow flying
everywhere torches burning fires and
smoke it feels like you're right there
to film the Battle of Winterfell HBO
built an enormous green screen in order
to bring their vision of an epic battle
to life so close gathered there for this
week's long shoot first we got the
unsullied and you're solid they're not
the only people from Essos who are part
of the Battle of NFL there are also the
Trekkie riders this is of course not
coming as a surprise at all since then
at the end of season seven is coming to
the fenman FL and she will arrive there
in season 8 premiere Germont will come
and Danny's forces during the battle
finally there's also shadow we think is
a Norton army and also there's a Chevy
shell on set we can also see it in the
official trailer multiple people will
vote flaming swords in the battle
against the dead out of all the
characters you know bearing the darién
is the only most closely associated with
a flaming sword in the next video we see
three people with flaming swords and
their own horseback seems like Ontarians
share the trick with a few people so far
we only have the official footage of
barrack building it ghost will have a
fair amount of screen time and will most
definitely fight this battle the last
time we saw ghost Johnston star wolf he
raised his head of the floor as his
master was resurrected from the dead
since I mentioned him once in season 7
but he never actually showed up on
screen there was actually a ghost scene
written for season 7
but if you cut there is very much time
to go with outside of Jan's most
consistent companion but according to
special effects supervisor Joe Bauer
that's all about to change
or you'll see him again and Bauer told
The Huffington Post he has a fair amount
of screen time in season eight he does
show up as a matter of fact I think
we'll release August in the official
trailer although many people disagree
that it's actually him in the background
anyways the night king is coming but
when our felon the living will be ready
when I'm fell now has a dug trench all
around it and everyone will - dragon
with weapons and shields the battle for
Winterfell will without a doubt be the
greatest battle sequence in the
television history
this battle is directed by Miguel
suppose Nick the guy behind some of the
best episodes of Game of Thrones like
hardhome vensim enter and battle the
bastards talking about this huge battle
forum NFL it's brutal said star peter
dinklage tyrion lanister he makes the
battle the bastards look like a theme
park writing earlier about this historic
sequence James Hebert called it
wall-to-wall action and detail how it
jumps between the stories of several
different characters as you might expect
this battle will leave many dead check
out this image of lifeless bodies strewn
across the ground outside of NFL's
settimana class we can see what looks
like a feel strong bodies to the left of
the castle including some that look like
horses meanwhile also got images of a
pile of body parts props outside the
castle and of the blood left on the
castle walls as it mana glass the
grounded Mangrum on quarry was littered
with bodies
unlike in money glass someone was able
to get up close and personal with the
bodies there all kinds of body said mega
maaan quarry the most surprising bodies
were the ones bearing the Kraken sigil
of house Greyjoy
I did not expect egregious to be part of
this battle but if Theon already saved
Yara by episode three then I don't see
where else they will be however it could
also be that you're on surprise attack
Winterfell gotta go on the company
either before or after the night king
attacked it anyways this is more in line
with what I was expecting
these skeletal bodies could be bodies to
whites or they could be of people flesh
fried by dragon fire
next up corpse blobs it will likely
spread these things all over the
battlefield and covers them in snow from
a distance they look like a discreet
bodies rather than a bunch of
is affixed one plate in this stays the
miss frost the direwolf mark robber as
well as the marker for Denison salad
forces but unfortunately the northern
army in the unsullied are not going to
be the only casualties for the living
it's confirmed that most of the Trekkie
will fall as well and they're surely
after be brought back to live by the
white walkers to act as their minions
here you can see the Trekkie whites
riding on horseback what we cannot say
for a fact although it's been hinted by
the official tease is that Daniel at
some point burn her former to check
eloia lists here we can see that the
Trekkie marker being burned does it for
share of Danny burn in the Trekkie that
fell during the battle for Venna fell
maybe after this epic Battle of
Winterfell denied him will Concord North
and the living or least what's left of
them will have to retreat south and once
again part of its arson urine and waste
in a span of 24 hours we got to season a
promise and one teaser and they gave a
vey far more than the trailer did not
only do we know for a fact the venom
fell is definitely falling to the night
king but in case you have not watched my
last video we also know where the living
will retreat after this one of the new
teasers provided this shot of Dana
standing in front of a fireplace but a
back turn to John and details on that
fireplace confirmed that they are a
gemstone take a look at all the details
on the shot from the fireplace itself to
its props the stone curves and metalwork
it's the very same thing we already saw
a general stone so now we know they will
retreat that Jurgen stone in Episode
four if the Winterfell falls to the
night king in Episode three I hope you
liked this little breakdown and please
let me know your thoughts about all of
this in the comment section down below
and as always I hope you guys enjoyed
this video if you did please make sure
to subscribe to our Channel and I hope
to see you in the next one peace